[Music]
tears of joy and relief after two-year
wait Brazil's indigenous peoples are
celebrating victory
9 out of 11 Supreme Court justices have
ruled in favor of their constitutional
rights to claim ancestral lands without
any time limits the vote was accompanied
by hundreds of indigenous leaders camped
outside the building
the decision is extremely important it
varies once and for all any attempt to
establish a time frame limiting our
claims to ancestral land and ultimately
canceling hundreds of them
powerful Farm Lobby has been arguing
that the government should only consider
some claims those made by tribes who are
occupying their lands in 1988. that was
the year Brazil's Democratic
Constitution was enacted giving
indigenous peoples rights to their
territories indigenous activists argued
the time frame was unfair Paul that many
tribes were expelled by force from their
territories during the two-decade
military dictatorship and could not
return to their lands without putting
their lives at risk since 2021 when the
Supreme Court started ruling on this
case indigenous leaders across Brazil
have been marching in the capital
Brasilia to make their voices heard
years of uncertainty have contributed to
land disputes between indigenous tribes
and Farmers loggers and miners the
Supreme Court decision should help put
an end to the violence but indigenous
leaders tell us that the battle is far
from over next week Brazil Senate is
expected to vote on a bill which would
open indigenous territories to
commercial activities the legislation
backed by the farm Lobby and the
conservative majority in Congress has
already been approved by the House of
Representatives if ratified it would
open a new chapter of debate about how
much Independence indigenous people have
to decide what will happen on their
lands Monica yanakiv Al Jazeera Rio de
Janeiro
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera